battlefield hardline turns out it's not
just a perpetual source of leaks but an
honest to goodness video game and you
know how I know that because I actually
got to play a couple hours of
multiplayer and it's pretty fun I mean
yes it's definitely a battlefield game
but it's also got some interesting
things going on first
there's the map design the one I played
on was a downtown Los Angeles map called
high tension and it's not the biggest
map in the world but it's definitely got
the most verticality to it in terms of
battlefield there's just so many layers
that you've got overpasses underpasses
multi-story parking garages skyscraper
rooftops and getting around all this
stuff with the new grapple hook and
zipline gadgets it's actually really fun
to items that work across all four
classes the grapple hook lets you climb
ledges where there's no ladder while the
zipline lets you quickly traverse wide
gaps without the risk of tumbling to a
grisly death if you're playing a game
mode like Blood Money where you're
running around with a bright red duffel
bag full of cash strapped to your back
avoiding surface streets by ziplining
between buildings can be a pretty
effective tactic it's also just fun
because it's a freakin zipline next up
vehicles they're still here it's a
battlefield game so there's vehicles one
difference though is that they feel a
bit more forgiving take the motorcycle
for example not only can you bash
through guardrails like it was nothing
you can also do these little wall rides
if you get close enough to a vertical
surface bigger vehicles seem a little
more durable to at least in so much as
they don't explode on impact if you
collide into something at more than 10
miles an hour plus there are special
vehicles that act as mobile spawn points
which is pretty cool but one word of
warning it might take a little while to
get used to the fact that all those
other vehicles parked around downtown LA
are just for show you can't get in them
don't even think about it so what about
the game modes what's new about those
well I got to play two of them heist and
blood money to be honest heist feels
pretty similar to rush at least in the
way in an attacking team has to crack
two vaults while the defenders try to
stop them the difference being that once
those vaults are cracked
the attackers then have to transport a
pair of briefcases to two different
escape
so there are some minor differences but
the whole flow doesn't really feel too
different from Rush now Blood Money is
different this mode is really cool and
seems to do a great job of tapping into
the whole cops-and-robbers setting
basically there's this pile of cash in
the middle of the map and both teams try
to take that money back to their own
armored trucks the thing is you can skip
the cash pile and go straight to the
other team's truck so there's a whole
lot of back-and-forth going on it's one
of those modes where you're constantly
weighing risks do I take the time to
grab another hundred thousand dollars
even though I hear enemy footsteps or in
another situation do I help a teammate
getting shot up even though I'm loaded
with cash and it's all made better by
the fact that you're not powerless when
you're carrying around that money you
can run at normal speeds and drive
vehicles it all feels like a bigger kind
of sloppier version of that famous
shootout scene from heat and that's hard
lines multiplayer in a nutshell there
are some fun new tweaks but you know for
better or worse it's still very much a
battlefield game want to know more well
be sure to head back to GameSpot in the
near future for more details on
everything from class differences to the
progression system - stay tuned